[Music]
hello my name is Magnus and I work in
the developer relations team here at
Google in this video I will show you how
to run the QuickStart app for the Google
Drive Android API a new API we just
launched that enables you to easily
create great Android apps that uses
Google Drive the prerequisites to run
this QuickStart is that you install the
Android SDK and Google Play services
both of these can be downloaded and
installed using the links displayed here
then we can get started the first step
is to download a kik QuickStart code
which is available on github under the
Google Drive folder once you have
downloaded this you should install it on
your computer then it's time to build
the app if you use Eclipse for example
you do this by creating a project select
new other Android project from existing
code select the code you just downloaded
then make sure to include the Google
Play services after that it's time to
build a project and generate the apk
file that will be later installed on the
Android device now we're going to
register the app with Google and the
first thing we need to do is to generate
the app signature in the form of a sha-1
and this picture may look really really
scary but it is actually very very easy
in your terminal window you execute the
keytool program of the Android SDK with
the command-line options highlighted in
the green box at the top enter the
default password Android hit enter and
take note of the sha-1 field being
displayed this is important as we will
need that value shortly now that we have
this value we can proceed to register
our app with Google and we use this we
use the Google Cloud console to do so
the following link will bring you to the
page where you can do this in the Google
console the first thing you want to do
is to create the project the only thing
really you need to fill out as part of
this process is the project name you
want to use then select the API is
alternative and make sure to enable
drive API by default the drive API is
disabled so you need to find it by
scrolling down and then switch it to the
on position
now we're ready to register our apps
which will have the drive API enables so
select registered apps to the right and
give the app a name then select Android
as the platform since we're building an
Android app and accessing our API is
directly from Android the last thing you
need to do when registering your app is
to enter the Java package name of your
app and the sha-1 value that we
previously generated using key tool and
with this we have successfully
registered that app with the Google
Cloud console and we are now ready to
execute the app I will demo the app on a
real physical device so in order to do
this I must transfer the apk to just
actual device this can be performed by
connecting the device and then using the
adb command from the Android SDK to
transfer the apk that we previously
built all done let's run the app so now
the application has started and I can go
in here and take a picture with the
camera that's a great picture I'm taking
that it's asking me to upload it to
drive so I'm accepting that then I can
go over to Drive and I can see the
picture being uploaded here and there it
is excellent so I took a picture and it
was uploaded to drive and that's it
we have now installed a run the
QuickStart app for the Google Drive
Android API there's also lots of more
sample code on github that you can
download and look at and now it's all up
to you so go out there and create some
great apps and don't forget to tell us
all about it